lu
autrefois c'était
doux l'aigle du
mer l'aigle de la mer ils étaient autrefois
douce lailla de la mer et autrefois ils étaient
doux l'aigle du
mer l'aigle de la mer perelo a crié un
Hitana et ils se sont transformés en sel mais ont pleuré un
IL
Ils sont revenus si tu veux je t'emmène Alo de
mon cheval oui je te porterai sur mon dos
cheval au milieu des pins
Vert au pied de la colline où j'étais, je ne l'ai pas pris
fleur
V n'aimait pas la fleur alors j'en ai retiré une autre
Il est venu et l'a pris et sans que j'en laisse un autre
est venu le
Il l'a pris et je ne lui ai pas donné la fleur alors il
J'ai retiré un autre vin, il l'a pris et alors j'ai
Je me suis retiré et un autre
[ __ ] si tu veux je te prends sur mon dos
cheval si tu veux je te prendrai sur le dos de
mon cheval au milieu des pins
Taco vert le loup